this new item to the lab peace be with
you thank you for tuning in to the Dean
show ohm our special guest eight years
old for all the parents turning in those
are thinking about having kids and those
who just want to learn about this way of
life we got an eight-year-old who's
going to explain it Islam is that simple
to understand that an eight-year-old
cannot only comprehend it but can
explain it we're going to be here to
share it with you bring them out to
share it with you in a minute so you
don't want to go anywhere we'll be right
back with Omar our next guest here in
the Dean show
this is the thing you know this is the
days of the theme this is the theme for
our mallesh Chrome what does that mean
please be pleased you party peace be
with you huh amazing how are you doing
you're 8 years old yes you graduated
from college
yeah not yet right and you're in what
grade are you in
hey sixth grade yes so you're an author
you've written some books yeah how many
books
how are you books - books are these
adult books or kids books
okay what are the name of the books
significance you know teeth I think is
legit oh hey Drock say it again
thank you - no teeth things that kids
are every kitchen know about teeth yes
I think if kiddo had washing what do you
want to be a dentist
no so teeth your dentist man so what's
the book about teeth how did he / teeth
at discrete all the time how to keep
your teeth clean all the time but they
don't fall out
yeah all right yes so what do you think
about all this candy too much sugar and
candy getting cavities what did you
spend that in the book at all no what do
you talk about in the book how you like
stopping how do you stop how do you stop
it by bushing et cetera eating too much
candy okay and eating too much candy no
I'm not eating too much candy okay great
so that's the first book so not eating
too much candy he's a lot of sugar and
you get cavities in your teeth fall out
right okay so and then brushing your
teeth no have huh hand washing and then
hand wat that's the other book yeah okay
what tell me about the other book hand
washing that was - I do keep it
I have clipped a kid he played all the
time I had to get beg drugs getting on
it how to make today delicious okay so
to avoid germs by cleaning all think so
many people don't know that we before we
pray before we makes a lot five times a
day minimum we make the preparation the
washing the special washing before we
pray yeah so you think it's very
important to be clean yes why because
the Prophet peace be upon him says that
clean this is half my face is the Book
of Allah
oh that's the hadith you mentioned a
hadith - so he said cleanliness is half
of our our Deen right okay so do you
have any aspirations any hopes to do
some more write some more books are you
in the process of writing some more
books yeah what are you thinking about
doing
steering stealing how to steal or how to
avoid stealing oh boy
avoid stealing okay good that's the next
project masha'Allah Omar let's talk
about Islam now okay because in this
program we like to educate all of
humanity you are tuning in from all over
the globe and I told them when I opened
the show that Islam is so simple because
it's from the Creator now I usually
define what it means but I'm not going
to do that because that's all I'm going
to ask you two questions now because I
said that Islam is so simple to
understand even a young boy such as
yourself a young child can understand it
and explain it so let's start with Islam
what is Islam actually mean Assad means
submission - of the crater that's it
submission to the will of the creator
about the Prophet and believing in all
the prophets and I'll end it there -
okay so that's don't leave my next
question so now you're mentioning the
articles of faith give me the article
the six articles of faith the belief
that's the belief of the Muslim was the
belief now so I asked you what the what
Islam meant you said Islam means what
hello [ __ ] to the Creator okay so now
what is the belief the articles of faith
a belief is
- winner only God ok Oh Georgie baby
hold on hold on hold on so belief in one
and only one God okay next it is just a
bit okay you got the day of judgment and
then the prophets to believe in the
prophets and then the Angels the angels
and then the books the books okay and
then the color the color the predestiny
okay so you got six so he got belief in
God the messengers the angels got the
day of judgment in there and the Destiny
the pre destiny this is the this is
either our articles of faith so now what
you mentioned some prophets okay can you
know the names of some of these prophets
yes well I don't know I Abraham Jesus
Moses summoned David and um and the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon them ah
that's the last prophet no more prophets
to come no more messengers he was the
seal of the prophets no more after him
but that's amazing because you said that
Islam means submission to the will of
God to the Creator you said the creator
and then all these messengers did they
come with Islam yes beautiful so some
people get these crazy ideas right
he lives sometimes you know we live in a
crazy world sometimes where we hear
crazy things right so it's our duty to
be good to do good and to help clear up
many of these misconceptions that people
have so one of these misconceptions
people have that Islam is maybe some
crazy cult or some terrorist religion
what do you say about that well as I've
as other evidence June of peace a
religion of peace didn't we when we
started the show I said assalamualaikum
yeah and that means what please please
would you write all right mashallah
we started with peace and we usually end
with peace but we're not going to end
why yet we're gonna take a break how's
that that cool all right we'll take a
break and we right back with more with
eight-year-old Omar here on the Deen
show so as the last and final messenger
sent to mankind the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him he told us to really
reflect often about death reflect upon
the destroyer of pleasures many of us
are delighting in our lusts and our
passions we're chasing this world we're
chasing that dollar we're chasing all
the material things we're working on our
physical physique and we're working on
our minds with the soul we're neglecting
it so before a situation comes where you
might end up in a hospital you might end
up with no legs you might end up with no
eyes you might end up in a situation
that you won't be able to even make a
prostration to your crater you won't
even be able to do the things that
you're doing now some of the hard hearts
that just have gone away that they've
made money they're gone they've made a
woman their God they've made a man their
God that's all they think about is the
next party or the next good time but as
you see if tomorrow you get hit by a
truck or a car or you fall from a fall
tall building or you get cancer or you
get a disease that you're not you're
your terminally ill and now you you lose
all these wonderful benefits take
advantage of your health now and use it
in the proper way if you're Muslim you
know that as Muslims we need to be
praying we need to be establishing that
direct connection with our career if
minimum five times a day we need to stay
away from the things that are
displeasing to the God Almighty we need
to pray to Him alone and not his
creation we need to follow the Sunnah
the way of the last and final messenger
sent to mankind and stay away from
gambling and alcohol and drugs
promiscuity
there's no dating in Islam and many of
the youth are caught up
on the Facebook and using them in an
unproductive way so if you see if you're
a young boy or young girl and you have
parents and you're disrespecting your
parent this can be you tomorrow it can
be you tomorrow that now your health
that now you might be playing soccer
baseball football and now you get hit
and you end up paralyzed or you end up
getting struck down and you're in the
hospital and it's almost flatline now is
the time that Angel of Death can come at
any time
medical mode he's there waiting so are
you prepared for that moment that moment
when your soul will be extracted from
your body are you ready to meet your
Creator when you're six feet under five
feet under in the ground and the dirt is
thrown over your body then it's too late
now is the time
Oh
Oh
you
back here on the Dean show with little
Omar here Salaam alaikum
thank you slap peace peace it's all
about peace isn't it I mean you're
learning Islam are you having fun
learning Islam yes is it simple to
understand yeah how many gods right how
about if someone said three gods just
one that's simple isn't it what's 1+1 2
- what if I said 1 plus 1 is 3 doesn't
make sense right yes 1 plus 1 is 2
ok simple you can understand that just
like 1 God is one God so God can't be 3
and 1 just 1
yes no Trinity yeah you've you heard of
this Trinity okay just one guy then
that's simple to understand you're I
mean want to prove a point that you know
even a child can understand this concept
of pure monotheism one God and don't
play with that one we don't add or
delete are you with me good luck so
let's go on some people think that
Muslims work worship a black box in the
desert what do you say about that
nope you only worship wouldn't God okay
what is this what is the box in the
desert a bark is a lie
you meant it that's right of Allah but
you know the Kaaba so what do Muslims do
at the black box the Kaaba what do we do
there poggle a pilgrimage that's it
simple so that brings me to my next
question okay you explained the six
articles the belief system of Muslims
okay you explained the belief in one God
belief in the angels the books the
messengers the day of judgment and
predestiny we got that out of the way
right okay simple let's go to the next
one
what about there's some pillars now if
you believe this now you have to act
upon it there's some actions required
those are the five pillars of Islam do
you know the five pillars
yes go ahead there's a Haida is the cat
duh um Hajj the fat the fast II and the
flocks a lot okay so
we can put those the Shahadah what's the
Shahadah do it is only one got and
what's the pit is another play and try
to lift engine and the final measure
problem hum peace be upon him okay so we
got the the look you're explaining Islam
because you understand the basics of it
and we want to prove a point that Islam
is that simple like I said that an
eight-year-old can understand it and
explain it so we've already got the
articles of faith we've cleared up one
misconception about the high we know we
clear the misconception about Islam and
some crazy ideas funny things that
people believe about Islam being like
some kind of cult or with terrorism and
you said no that's not true right yeah
ok because why because it's about it so
total we would God and you said
something about peace okay so now let's
let's move along let's go ahead with
this word Muslim because I think it's
also very important to define words we
defined the word Islam what is the word
Muslim mean yeah what Muslim means
submission tool of the one and only
creator that's the one who does Islam
Muslim what does it mean to be a Muslim
and to be a Muslim means to be kind to
family where I will attend that maybe
but the powerful piece you parlance is
the kind of is the mark of face and we
live with no parent has little face I
like that and you quoted the last and
final messenger peace be upon him
Muhammad who was a brother to Jesus
Moses Abraham you know they were
brothers right they came with the same
message worship the Creator not the
creation
how about worshipping the Sun now how
about worshiping the moon no how about
worshiping Muhammad yeah
how about worshiping Jesus holy ghost
yeah nothing how about money
yeah just God just the crater yeah I
like that game 5
haha yes okay so moving along we so you
said being kind to your parents who else
being kind to family family friend
friends neighbors neighbors and
relatives yes and who said this and the
part might be the last and final
messenger and someone who doesn't have
and this is a what a sign of of what I
said kesa kind of in the mark of faith
and what really that kind of low faith
kindness is a Marcus of faith and
whoever is not kind has no faith yes so
that's another teaching of asan that's
what it means to be a Muslim to be kind
to all these different groups of people
amazing people are learning so much from
you an eight year old young man how do
you feel Emmet Mary a little bit nervous
are you having fun yeah masha'Allah so
if Islam tells us and it means to be
kind obviously does it does it now teach
us to to art to hate people to be mean
to people who are not Muslim does it
teach that nope it teaches to be kind to
people to be kind to people yeah great
that's that's what Islam is all about
and you're learning it here on the Deen
show with Omar eight years old written
two books two books how to keep clean
and all and to keeping your teeth clean
and your hands clean you started off
with these simple basic topics God
willing as you get older you move on you
talked about moving on to talk about how
to how to not steal okay great so you're
already in joining good right and you
want to be a die when you grow up
someone who calls people to worship the
creator or not the creation yes yeah
inshallah so we talked about Islam what
that means submission to the will of the
creator we talked about what the
articles of faith the pillars and
hopefully God willing that the people
the viewers who are tuning in from all
over the
world many of them adults are getting to
learn about Islam from an eight-year-old
kid hamdulillah Quran you know about the
car huh what's the Quran next question
what's the crowd the crowd is the blood
does real to the Prophet peaceful pie
okay you mentioned before when we spoke
that there was it came where to come
from did it go straight from from the
Creator to Prophet Muhammad how to the
angel Gabriel then a cake to the party
ok so from the from the Creator to the
our angel Gabriel Gabriel lays LOM and
then to the Prophet peace be upon him
and how many versions because people
don't know some people don't know that
there are countless versions of let's
say the Bible for instance we're not
talking about translations you have you
have so many versions ok but how many
versions of the Quran do you have only
one will you say c'est que dad only one
yes not a dozen or 300 versions yeah ok
the same it was revealed to problem
honey PC Aparna
yes that's how we have it yeah alright
now that you've explained what the Quran
is it's from the Creator is given to
angel Gabriel to the problem peace be
upon him millions have memorized the
Quran you know that millions and we have
it today in its original do you know
some of the crowd
yeah can you recite some of the Quran
please go ahead I was little a - a Thai
Reggie miss M'Lynn rahmanir rahim well
who a long war had a loss of it got
minute while amulet Ambika look of
wonder hey say he's a lot of the one and
only a lot of a to relax lute yep tit
yeah no children and no he bored and
then listen to pay well up to it that is
beautiful that's from the verbatim word
of God from the Creator who sent the
Quran to man
kind to tell human beings that there's
only one God he's absolute he's eternal
he doesn't sleep does God you sleep
right you get tired
God doesn't get tired he doesn't sleep
Allah is truly self-sufficient he's the
Creator he doesn't eat or sleep do you
eat yes after you eat you drink also
because you get thirsty what do you have
to do after you eat or drink usually you
say do octavian okay to do all but then
do you have to do you have to sometimes
go to the bathroom yeah everyone has to
go to the bathroom right but God he
doesn't eat or sleep or do any of these
things that's what he's saying in this
ayah that he's truly self-sufficient he
doesn't need anyone or anything he
doesn't even have to doubt for one one
you know for one one information right
he doesn't need nobody so and then
there's nothing comparable to him
anything that you can put in your mind
that's not God that's not the Creator is
a lot the most loving easy the most kind
you he's the most kind the most merciful
that's right that's the Creator and
there's nothing comparable to him we're
gonna take a break can we take a break I
know you got a busy schedule can you
stick around for a few more minutes
you sure okay we'll be right back with
Omar here on the Deen show it's like
when did you think that you had no
purpose
are you worthless the value comes from
purpose your purpose in life is to
worship the Creator no worship your
desires himself not worship social
pressure the celebrity culture but
worship the thing that's much higher and
transcendent above and beyond by
worshipping God and seeking his pleasure
you get pleased so you have double
pleasure
I am Not Afraid to stand alone I am Not
Afraid to stand alone if Allah is by my
side I am Not Afraid to stand alone I am
Not Afraid to stand alone if Allah is by
my side
I am Not Afraid to stand alone I am Not
Afraid to stand alone
if Allah is by my side I am Not Afraid
to stand
back here on the D show eight-year-old
Omar on the Deen show are you happy to
be on the Deen show yeah you want to say
hello to anybody how about your brothers
and sisters go say Salaam - what's your
brother what's your brother's name okay
Tom Salam alaikum
hey kit hahaha how about your mom and
dad you want to sell Salam
yes thank you okay so let's keep a few
more questions okay before we call it
quits
most people some people have another
misconception that all Muslims are Arabs
is that true no muscle can be for any
good treat China yes
Pakistan yes Britain yes you could be a
Muslim if you're German yes American yes
okay
beautiful so that's not true then that's
it that's not true that all Muslims are
Arabs yes it's it's true or not
yes actually it's not true beautiful
okay so you helped clear up another
misconception okay we got that out of
the way do you plan on so you're in
sixth grade
yes what do you want to be when you grow
up I'll be yeah how for them cause
they're only a belief Masha Allah Hafiz
Quran so Hafiz crown is someone who's
also memorized the Quran beautiful
that's a miracle of the Quran that
millions upon millions living people
have memorized the Quran do you know
that let me share something with you you
know that all of the books all of the
religious books were thrown away into
the ocean or you burned them and you
couldn't bring any of them back except
the Quran do you know that that's a fact
why because it's been memorized and a
half is is one who's memorized the Quran
mashallah hamdulillah okay so I'm going
to ask you a final question you ready we
talked about Islam so the person viewing
now maybe he's watched some of our shows
and he is fascinated his heart accepts
what's in his very nature that you only
worship the Creator not the creation
right
and we talked about I mentioned
worshiping the Sun what do you say
no no worshiping the moon no worshiping
the stars no worshiping a man no
worshipping a woman no we should be
money no worshipping cards no nothing
only only God only the creator the maker
of mankind so that's what a Muslim means
that's what Islam is we went over the
articles of faith we won't we run over
the pillars because talk is cheap you
got to act upon what you believe so how
does one become a Muslim now if they
love what we're talking about and they
just they're sick of taking it easy they
want to do it now they're sick of
procrastinating and they're ready to
take the step forward what do they have
to do after you just the Raiders doctor
a little god but God either woman has
this prophet say it one more time they
have to testify that there's no God
there's no god but God and Muhammad and
Mohammed is a prophet is his final
prophet that's it so you believe in all
these things now you have to testify did
you hear that so if you're one of those
people right now and you firmly you want
to please your Creator before you meet
your Creator the maker of mankind you
believe that there's nothing worthy of
worship but God there's no god but God
because money some people take money is
a guy these things that I've listed the
moon the Sun man
Saints some people actually worship
these things so to accept Islam you have
to first negate these things right say
I'm not going to worship any of these
things there's no god but God and
Muhammad is the messenger you're not to
worship any and that's it then you could
be a Muslim all right beautiful
all right that's it that was easy right
did you have fun yeah all right thank
you for being with us here in the Deen
show give salams to your whole family
we'll see you next time okay all right
peace
wish to see we started with peace and we
end with peace peace be with you
and that was Omar our guest eight years
old
author already of two books and he
discussed both from things every kid
should know
teeth and things every kid should know
hand-washing amazing kids at a young age
getting a good start and I hope that you
got to learn some of the basic beliefs
of Islam and Muslims what it means to be
a Muslim being kind to your family kind
to your neighbors kind to those members
of society Muslim or non-muslim and then
we went even deeper what Islam actually
means is Lama has nothing to do with
terrorism terrorizing people killing
innocent men women and children no it
doesn't have nothing to do with that you
got it wrong there it's la means
submission to the will of the creator
and an 8 year old kid knows that and you
don't subhanAllah come on now
so you are getting exposed to the truth
and now you're ready to accept the truth
are you if you're sincere with yourself
and you give birth to what's already
inside of you you've already taken the
Shahada if you missed out on it and you
want to hear it again it's just to
testify that there's nothing I'm not
going to worship any woman or man a
saint an angel a messenger like Jesus
peace be upon him he'll never call
people to worship Him he called people
to worship the creator the maker of
mankind and if you're ready to do that
right now that's it a shadow and la la
hey la la la shadow ni muhammadan abduhu
wa rasuluh I bear witness there's
nothing worthy of worship except the
creator of the heavens in the earth
there's no god but God and Muhammad is
the final messenger and that would
include Jesus Moses Abraham and all the
preceding messages who came with the
same message worship the Creator do good
deeds and prepare for the day of
judgment because death is a reality and
when death comes is too late bye bye so
do it right now you can even call us